-Our next guest is a very
talented actor and comedian
you know from his work
on "Single Parents"
and "Saturday Night Live."
He is now back on Broadway
starring in "Spamalot,"
which is playing
at the St. James Theatre.
Please welcome back to the show
our good friend Taran Killam,
everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome back.
-Hi, my friend.
-Thank you for being with us
on your off night.
-Thank you for having me.
And not an off night.
We're -- Monday shows.
-Monday shows?
-Monday shows.
So buy a ticket to "Spamalot."
It's very funny.
-Oh, my God.
-Yeah.
-Now, I will say "Spamalot,"
when it first came to Broadway,
I mean, I think like you loved
the film so much.
-My whole life.
-Did not know what to expect
from the play.
It was above and beyond
my wildest dreams.
Did you see it back
in the day?
-I never got to see it.
I knew the album very well.
I knew the songs
that were original
to the Monty Python films,
like "Knights of the Round
Table" and "Always Look
on the Bright Side,"
and then the new ones too.
You know,
I live in Los Angeles now.
-Yeah.
-I have two children
who are beautiful and say hello,
and I did not think
that I would be doing theater
until they were like
kicked out of the house.
So I cannot believe
that not only
am I doing a musical
on Broadway again,
but it's a Monty Python musical.
It's just like the perfect,
perfect job for me.
-You have been very lucky
with the times
that you've dipped your toe...
-This is true.
-...into Broadway.
You did a run
on "Hamilton" as well.
-Yes.
-"Hamilton" is a musical?
-It's a musical.
It's like, you know $10?
You ever seen $10?
-We've all seen $10.
And so you got to play
King George in "Hamilton,"
which is a real juicy part.
-It's the cushiest job
on Broadway.
You sing the same song
three times,
you wear a funny cape
and everybody laughs at that.
It was an extraordinary
experience.
And I'm working
so much harder now.
-Yes.
[ Laughter ]
-I've made a terrible mistake.
-Well, I want to ask about that.
Yeah, you made a terrible
mistake,
but you have again, way more,
but these are the juicy
parts as well -- Lancelot.
Yes, but you're also
the French taunter.
-This is correct.
-One of the Knights Who Says Ni.
-Yep.
-Among others.
-Yes.
-And it must be for somebody
who loved the movie...
-Yeah.
-...it must have been
so easy to get off book.
Not to make it easier
than it was, but...
-100%, I mean,
and the challenge, if anything,
is to not directly mimic Cleese.
-Right.
-But also honor it,
because I think
a lot of the audience
that's showing up
has expectations of like,
"I know how to say Ni."
-Yeah.
-"That's not how they say Ni."
But yeah, as we're doing
eight shows a week,
like, you find new wrinkles
to kind of make it your own,
but you want to honor
the source material.
And Eric Idle,
who co-wrote the show
with John Du Prez,
has been around.
He's been hanging out
for the last week
and giving notes
and compliments.
-Well, now I want
to say real quick like I...
So I texted you because
I had never met Eric Idle,
and I met him recently
because he was in town
for opening night.
-Yes.
-And I, you know,
I got a chance to tell him
how much I loved the show
when it first opened
and how excited I was.
And he went out of his way
to say how great you were.
And I know how much
it means to you.
I want to show the wide first.
You posted this on Instagram.
So that's the great Eric Idle.
But the look on your face when
you cut in.
This is a man...
[ Laughter ]
This is a man receiving
a compliment from his hero.
-Yes. Yes.
-It's really great.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Really, really lovely.
-All of my castmates
were like,
"Oh, that's what it looks like
when you're sincere."
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-They're like, "Everything
nice you've said to us
is a whole different face."
-"You phony!"
-Yeah.
You have received -- You
did receive great reviews.
You opened last week.
Congratulations very much.
And I know that's no small thing
when you are reviving a show
that was so well received,
however many years ago,
15, 17 years ago.
-It does feel like
the bar has been raised
because, you know, Hank Azaria
originated the role in 2005,
and I'm a huge fan of his.
But we received, in my opinion,
the highest plaudit possible
in our first week.
We had to refund a ticket.
We had to rebook a ticket
because someone complained,
because the person
next to them was laughing
so hard they wet themselves.
-Wow.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
-100% true story.
What could you want more
from a Monty Python musical
than "this show is so funny,
people are literally
wetting themselves"?
-Wetting themselves enough
that their adjacent seat...
-Are aware of it.
-Aware of it.
-There's a splash zone
to the urination.
-They didn't wet their seat.
They wet two seats.
-Exactly. You like it
so much you'll wet two seats.
Joel de Ridder,
one of our crew members,
came up with
the perfect tagline.
If we can put it on our marquee,
you're in for a treat.
[ Laughter ]
-Very good.
[ Applause ]
Very good.
One might say, yeah.
-You know what I mean?
-You know, and maybe
it was a little shame on me,
but I remember because
when I was growing up,
that was one of those VHS,
"Monty Python and Holy Grail,"
not every kid watched.
I felt like maybe
the comedy kids watched.
And so when I went
and saw the show on Broadway,
I was very taken
with the fact of like,
oh, everybody was on
to this movie
because there is
that greatest hits feel of,
"oh, I know this scene
and I know how it's played,"
and people were
in the best mood,
and it just must feel
like such a gift
to be able to sort of be the new
steward of this material.
-It is exactly that.
Our first preview
was Halloween night.
People showed up in costume.
There are many moments where I'm
not able to get out my dialogue
before people finish it for me,
which is a treat
because this show kind of allows
you to incorporate the audience.
And so there's
a looseness there.
But I think Josh Rhodes,
our director,
really did a great job
of freshening it up,
of tightening it, but also
kind of giving us permission
to make it our own and
to update relevant references.
And in moments where there's
some improv and looseness,
you know,
we're able to go off book.
Leslie Kritzer,
who plays Lady of the Lake,
who is mind-blowingly
talented and good,
steals the show
during "Camelot"
because she does
a whole lounge act
that's like 100% original
every night.
-Wow.
-And I say that
so that hopefully people
will come back multiple times.
-There you go.
-I think the show is that good.
-Now that
we've finished the good news,
I know you are
a Los Angeles Rams fan.
-Big, big R-- Whose house?!
[ Laughter ]
Damn it!
-That was...
-Damn it!
-...the most -- I think that
might be the most
over one's skis
a guest has ever been.
[ Laughter ]
I like how you were like people
yell out your lines on Broadway.
It must feel like
the opposite of that.
-Yeah, that's why I did that.
-So I know on social media,
I feel like if you're in town,
you go to the game.
-Yes.
-Right?
-I have season tickets
right in the front row.
I love it. Yeah.
-And it seems like,
you know, like this --
-Rampage?
-This guy --
-His name is Rampage?
-Rampage is a personal friend.
He came to the show last night.
-Oh, wow. That's great.
-People said, why is there a 6
1/2-foot ram walking the stage?
I said because he's my bro
and he knows that
whose house, Rams house.
-Oh, wow.
That doesn't seem that...
-And yeah, now we're 4-6.
-Yeah. Whose house?
Whoever came to play in this...
[ Laughter ]
Those guys' house.
-Yeah.
That's mostly true this season.
-Yeah, that's mostly true.
-Since they've came back to
L.A.,
it's been very good for you.
-Yes. Yeah, yeah.
I'm very involved with the team.
I was on the jumbotron
just on Sunday
when we beat the Seagulls.
[ Laughs ]
You are not a football crowd!
[ Laughter ]
-Well, they're also not
called the Seagulls.
-They are in the Rams' house.
-Oh, my God.
[ Laughter ]
So it feels very confusing
to be at a Rams game.
So, alright. You were
in the "Spider-Verse."
-Yeah.
-What was your Spider-Man name?
-I had the honor of playing
Web-Slinger in "Spider-Man:
Across the Spider-Verse."
Phil Lord, Chris Miller,
producers,
writers of of those films,
knew I was a huge fan,
but they also knew I can --
I'm cheating because I can see
what he's holding --
that I had written the comic
book issue for Web-Slinger.
-So you had already written it?
-I had already written this,
this single issue of
Web-Slinger,
which is like Cowboy Spider-Man.
And then Chris and Phil
called me up and they said,
"Hey, do you want to do
like five lines in the movie
and like one of the biggest
movies of the year?"
And I thought about it
for a while.
-Played hard to get.
-I played hard to get.
Saw a couple Rams games!
-Oh, boy.
-No? Okay. Yeah.
No, it was a dream.
It was -- It was --
It's the coolest.
-I took my -- You know,
it's a two-parter.
You know that because --
-I'm very aware. Yeah.
-I don't have
to tell you anything.
You're ahead of the game.
So I brought my boys to see it.
And we saw it.
And I don't know if other people
knew it was going to be
a two-parter.
-Yeah, there's a lot of story
in that first chapter.
-There's a lot of story
in the first chapter.
And my kids,
they're just happy to see like
Spider-Man on the on the screen.
They're not...
But it ended and it was like,
you know,
part two coming next year.
And the woman behind us
was like, "What the [bleep]?"
[ Laughter ]
-Oh!
-And again, it's a Spider-Man.
It's all kids.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
You wanted a "what the thwip."
-Yeah, or just like, you know,
just like,
take it with a grain of salt.
-Like, "Well, I guess
we're coming back, honey."
-Yeah, you're going to come back
and see another movie.
She's like,
"I can't go around the rest
of my Saturday
not knowing what happens."
-Yeah. Sorry.
On behalf of --
As the most important
representative
of "Across the Spider-Verse,"
let me just say, ma'am,
I'm sorry,
but you won't be angry
when Part 2 comes out.
-You were also in a remake
of "The River Wild."
-Correct.
And we took away the "the."
-Oh, it's just "River Wild"?
-Just "River Wild" for us.
-Oh, that's great.
That's so much better.
-It's classier.
[ Laughter ]
It takes less time to get
to how wild that river is.
-The "the" was my least
favorite part of the original.
-Same, same, same. No.
It was amazing.
And it was received very well
and was number two on Netflix
at one point.
But I couldn't talk about it.
So we were number two
on Netflix!
-There you go.
Now you're making up for it.
-But we shot in Hungary.
We shot in Budapest.
Mostly.
That's where we were located.
And I recreated one
of my favorite "Late Night
with Seth Meyers" segments.
-You went day drinking?
-I went day drinking. By myself.
-By yourself.
So that's less fun than doing it
with another person.
-Yeah, you'd think so but
honestly, I can't remember.
-So is this a --
This is an ice bar?
-That's where we started.
-Okay.
-It's 11:45 a.m.
-Okay. Oh, wow.
And do you have to wear,
like, an ice coat?
-Or else you'll die!
-Oh, wow.
And then this is what,
like, bar trivia?
-This is bar trivia.
Like a comic book-themed bar
there. That was just a bar.
An aptly named bar.
This is karaoke.
-Oh, wow.
-I met up
with a friend for karaoke.
It's not as sad as it seems.
-It's still pretty sad!
[ Laughter ]
And then...
-Alright.
And this is Rumpus.
This is my favorite tiki bar
I've ever been to.
If you find yourself
in Budapest, go to Rumpus.
They have the Death Race
Challenge. And by this point --
-What is a Death Race Challenge?
These drinks?
-These drinks that are
increasingly more alcoholic.
-Okay.
-And if you win,
you get a little yellow token.
-So this is what you do for
your alcohol poisoning?
-Let's just say
I survived the Death Race.
-Wow, Taran, you've had
such a big year.
-Of all the accomplishments.
-That's the best one.
-Yes.
-Hey. Thank you, buddy.
Break a leg tonight.
-Thank you.
-Taran Killam, everybody.
You can see Taran in "Spamalot,"
which is playing at
the St. James Theatre on
Broadway.
We'll be right back with more
"Late Night."